national governments have taken strong
measures to limit the spread of the
coronavirus in the European Union this
is necessary but some of these measures
have stopped people at the borders at
certain borders we have dozens of
kilometres of traffic jams and more than
24 hours of waiting time many European
citizens are still unable to travel back
home and trucks carrying medicine
essential and perishable goods such as
food are blocked it is important to
solve this now right at the beginning of
the crisis and that's why I follow the
situation closely including thanks to
satellite images from Copernicus I had
several talks with national governments
addressing this topic and there are
already some good developments last
weekend we had a huge traffic jam at the
Sylvanian Croatian border now traffic is
much more fluid there people are now
able to reach their homes the lorry
stranded in Slovenia could continue to
their destination this is a good example
and how neighboring countries can find
pragmatic solutions we also had long
traffic jams at the borders between
Poland the Czech Republic Germany and
lasagna we worked on it people coming
from the Baltic States can now return
home to Estonia Latvia and Lithuania and
traffic for lorries is getting better
too but we still have problems at some
borders yesterday we still had more than
20 kilometers of jams at the border
between Hungary and Romania we need to
find a solution there too many Romanians
and Bulgarians still wait to get home
and the trucks loaded with goods must
continue their route I hope tomorrow we
will see a better situation at this
border to